you gotta be kidding me you're gonna
risk the entire mission for a mental
defective dress as a court justice it's
coming from a guy that wears a toilet
seat on his head we don't leave one of
our own behind
hopefully harley's still alive no funny
business i don't
these are dangerous people team two is
clear to go
fire uh three two what are you guys
doing
what you we're here to save you you were
gonna save
me it was a really good plan too well i
can go back inside and you can still do
it that's patronizing i'm so sorry
harley quinn bloodsport
[Music]
you know the deal successfully complete
the mission
you get 10 years off your sentence
[Music]
you fail to follow my orders in any way
and detonate the explosive device in the
base of your skull
this is the famous suicide squad
any questions
and yes that is your hand very good
we're all gonna die i hope so
oh for [ __ ] sake here's the deal
we fail the mission you die we find out
any information you give us is false
you die if we find out you have
personalized license plates
you don't what no if you cough without
covering your mouth early although
that isn't an open invitation for you to
cough without covering your mouth
what's the plan how the hell must listen
though you're the leader you're supposed
to be decisive and i've decided that you
should eat a big bag of dicks
but this whole beach was completely
covered in dicks and somebody said i'd
eat every dick until the beach was clean
for liberty i would say no problem
why would someone put penises all over
the beans who knows why mad men do what
they do
this is suicide well that's kind of our
thing
[Music]
are you worried i'm gonna get you out of
your life i'm going to get you
out of here alive
oh my god we've got to freaking kaiju up
in this [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
i love the rain the angels are splooting
all over
us
you